amigo leopoldo lópez ya está en españa
tras haber pasado año y medio en la
embajada española en caracas y burlar la
custodia a las afueras de la sede
diplomática llegó este domingo a madrid
así lo confirmó su familia y más tarde
el ministerio de exteriores español
leopoldo lópez ha llegado hoy domingo a
madrid
pudiéndose reunir con su familia su
llegada se produce después de haber
permanecido como huésped en la
residencia de la embajada de españa en
caracas desde el 30 de abril de 2019 la
decisión de salir de la embajada es una
decisión personal y voluntaria
lópez fue encarcelado en el 2014 tras
liderar protestas contra nicolás maduró
después de tres años en la cárcel fue
transferido a arresto domiciliario desde
su casa fue mentor del líder de la
oposición juan guaidó quien a principios
del año pasado
invocó la constitución para asumir una
presidencia interina y comenzó una
campaña para desbancar a
en abril de 2019 cuando trató de
estimular una revuelta militar contra
maduro lópez apareció de nuevo en las
calles junto a él cuando la revuelta
fracasó lópez buscó refugio primero en
la residencia diplomática chilena y
luego en la casa del embajador español
[Música]
no vamos a descansar ni un solo minuto
vamos a descansar bajo ninguna
circunstancia en el reto y el compromiso
que nos hemos trazado que es lograr el
cese lo sur pasión el opositor
venezolano anunció a través de twitter
que abandonar su país fue una decisión
difícil también aseguró que en los
próximos días anunciará las acciones que
se propondrá para seguir la lucha desde
el exterior